but most guys
the reason why they get into really bad
relationships the reason why
the divorce rate is what it is the
marriage rate gets pushed back even
further
for men it's like 29 for women it's 28
maybe even 30 by now
we've pushed the rate of or the
incidence of first marriage
further and further into our 30s right
now the reason for that is not because
guys want to be
adolescents it's not because guys want
to you know even even guys who don't
want to get married
it's because those are the realities of
the sexual marketplace right now
it's not because of your choice it's
because women just don't want anything
to do with you and men don't want to
have anything to do with women
because they don't want to run through a
girl and she doesn't want a guy who's
economically unattractive or is it jus
is a guy who just doesn't get it but the
reality is
is that the guys who are getting into
relationships right now who are serial
monogamists who find themselves oh man i
can't believe i found this this one
great girl they're all into
self-deprecation
uh and they think that that's their form
of game the reason why they get into
these bad relationships
is because they think they have to
because they have been what i've
termed this in the past they are
pre-whipped they're already whipped by a
girl they haven't even
met yet because they believe that the
expectation of them by the blue pill
that's conditioned them for this
they believe that when they get into
that that relationship
it's gonna be hard work it's gonna
relationships take
effort and i gotta really freshen it up
and it's this qualification that
not only do they have when they're
single now that they're married it's
this
constant qualification and you better do
it right and you better do these things
right and you better make her feel
special
and you better not make her think that
there's another girl that wants to get
with you that's why when we talk about
dread
it's such a foreign like alien thought
to guys
to actually go with it because for most
guys most beta guys
they don't want their wives or their
girlfriends to think that they're
flirting with the
with the waitress or whatever and rather
than going with that
and having you know maybe you know
dealing with the with the fallout from
the woman
but at least it's an indication of
pre-selection
that works for you guys who aren't in
that mentality
they're thinking oh wait wait baby uh
you're the only girl for me
and and they they'll they'll suck up to
her or they'll placate to her
because they want to make her feel
secure you're the only girl for me don't
worry about it
because they're worried about that loss
the reason why
where that comes from is not from within
marriage it comes prior to that
it comes pro it's your upbringing it's
your thinking it's your serial monogamy
it's it's trying to prove yourself as
that unique guy amongst all these other
guys
because to the blue pill beta mindset
everybody's a player
everybody's screwing these girls
everybody and maybe they're right
because the girls that they're going for
are the players but not the 80 not the
vast majority of guys
the vast majority of guys are guys who
want to prove themselves as being
a good husband and a good match and a
good catch right
and so when they get into those
relationships now it's not so
now it's they don't understand how to
turn their wives on whatsoever
and certainly not as much as the guys
who turned her on
in her college years when she was at her
sexual market value peak
but what they don't understand is that
when when they get into these
relationships
women's sexual market value changes
it it's on the decline and they're lucky
to have you
but they will never think that because
they've been preconditioned
from their earliest childhood to just
thank their lucky stars to say oh
i got lucky i got fortunate it's divine
intervention whatever it is
that i'm even with this person and so
it's this constant qualification
even when that woman's value is next to
nothing certainly nothing as what it
used to be
when she was in her twenties when she
was in her mid-twenties
you